i'm
bob stan heinrich i'm a developer here
at wolfram
and today i'm going to be talking about
some
fun side projects i've done so today i'm
talking about
uh quickly turning fun ideas into
projects that mostly work so
i've been working at wolfram for a while
i've given a few talks
and up until now they've all been sort
of about my job
and i try to make the presentations fun
but usually
the the subject matters is kind of dry
and it's you know important good stuff
to know about
but uh this one this one is not about my
job
this is about what i do
for fun sometimes with wolfram language
when i'm not even getting paid to do it
um
so and as as you can see there
uh uh there will be jokes
and due to the remote virtual nature of
this
i will just assume that you all find
them hilarious
all right um so like i said i've been at
wolfram for a while now
and i do almost all of my development
in wolfram language and this has side
effects
so the sort of computational mindset has
crept into my brain
and it affects the way i think about
things
uh the wolfram language is highly
automated this has
benefits if i want to pursue something
in the wolfram language
it it can happen quickly and the most
important thing that can happen quickly
is finding a dead end so if you
want to go down some path just for fun
you don't want to waste a bunch of time
and you don't want to spend a bunch of
time just to learn if you're wasting
time
then you'll run into the sunk cost
issues and end up wasting more time
on a dead end it's terrible but
everything's highly automated you can
get a proof of concept in a prototype in
minutes
for most projects and that's a huge
benefit
and then another thing that's important
the wolfram cloud
exists and is getting better every year
and this has consequences
and that is you are all going to be
subjected to my hacky side projects
and also you can whip out
your fun hacky side projects at all
those cocktail parties that we're all
going to
and impress your friends who you know
are
english majors uh and and they can
they can see they're cool things you can
send them a link and they'll see it on
their phone and be like oh there's a
thing that does a thing
how is that happening it's magic so this
so this presentation is basically a
rundown of three
if we have time maybe more uh quick fun
hacky side projects or as i will call
them
kfips all right
so the first kefips is pie slices daily
um so uh
pie slices daily i'm gonna sort of break
down the origin story
about how it came about and then and
then we'll
we'll look at it at the end so uh if you
are familiar familiar with my pi day if
you follow wolfram on
on twitter um then you probably
have seen browser's on the wrong screen
here we go you've probably seen my pi
day it's the website
you go in you put in your birthday or or
any day
you can lie you can tell us whenever you
want and it tells you
where your birthday is in pie and you
can get a t-shirt
and you know beautiful
beautiful design work um but
the the you know every year this sort of
gets a spike of traffic
it sort of re-enters my consciousness
and what what's really amazing is that
like the computational part of this
is super trivial more from language
right so it's almost this
this is what i'm using to make slice of
pie so it says
give me 15 digits supply starting at the
20th digit right so if we
look at 35 it's the last
15 here right so and yeah you can go
you can go pretty darn deep and it
doesn't take too long right
um so 2 million digits in and that took
less than a second so getting digits out
of pi is amazingly trivial i'm not
a math expert i don't know how what
algorithms are used here
i know it's impressive but
i like to use it all right so the next
piece for pie slices daily is a
twitter service connection uh so service
connections have been around for a few
versions now
and what you can do is you can say this
it takes you to your browser
i'm logged into twitter i can authorize
it
it says go back to wolfram language so
here i go back
and now i can use twitter from
my notebook so i can say get all the
tweets from will from research
and so here's here's all the here's all
the the last
you know 20 tweets or something uh oh
look right here
they're talking about me um all right
and then
importantly for this conversation
there's also
a way to send tweets so instead of
saying tweet list i can say tweet
and i can give it a message and i can
tweet this out
and then i'll go back back to twitter
here
and see here's here's here's my tweet
all right so that's fun
uh so that's the second piece the third
piece
is cloud deployed schedule tasks so
uh scheduled tasks running in cloud have
been around for a while
and but i don't think people use them
enough so i'm gonna advocate for them
because they're very powerful
and they they really let you do make fun
products in the world so here uh i have
some code that's not
very impressive by the way this whole
talk none of the code's impressive
so if you're looking for something
impressive there's other talks going on
i think anton antonov is giving a talk
right now
his code is always impressive but this
talk is about
evangelizing a process all right
so you can take the temperature in st
louis subtract the temperature in
champagne
and i added a little time stamp to that
and i'm putting it
at the end of a cloud object so every
ever and then every six hours this is
gonna run the cloud so it's just gonna
take the difference in those
temperatures and put it in a cloud
object so i have
this scheduled task that uh has been
running since i started putting the
stock together
two or three weeks ago and now if i
use read list on this cloud object i get
back all of these
time stamps with temperature differences
and i can plot it
um so you know the computation the code
here isn't revolutionary but
scheduled tests and cloud work and they
let you just sort of
create create things that are effective
so
we got those three pieces we got slices
of pie that are super easy to get
we've got tweeting from wolfram language
which is super easy
and we've got i gotta reach up higher
for you to see it and we've got
uh cloud deployed scheduled tasks and
the end result
is pi slices daily twitter one of the
greatest
web pages in the world 11 followers
that's one more than yesterday
uh so every day for over a year now
it's tweeted out the next slice of pie
280 more characters of pie
uh and my my dream is that one of you
will will verify that it that it's
correct
and if you find uh wrong wrong one i
will uh
i will send you a sandwich
from ubereats all right um and if you
want to see the code
it's here in my github so
this is all 195 lines of
which is probably half white space so
yeah and most of this is just air
handling whenever you're doing
sort of server server communication you
need to handle it when somebody
just sort of completely falls over um
so half of that is uh
uh just just for air handling
all right so that was our first cafeps
now we can move on
to our second kfips random haiku
generator uh so i work with the function
repository
a lot as my actual job i develop it and
i
review some content for the function
repository and about a year ago
mark greenberg published word syllables
so this is a function that it
what it does is simple but how it does
it is surprisingly
complex um so it just takes a word and
splits in syllables
seems like that might be an easy thing
but linguistics is
is it's tricky so but
it works well like i can rarely find i
think only once i've seen
one that it got wrong um but i saw this
function that was
you know some serious coding and
required you know uh
expertise and study and i decided i
could do something stupid with it
something quick hacky and fun uh so i
made another resource function
random english haiku and uh
and so it just takes it just uses that
syllables to split up words and then
finds words that
fit into a haiku and and
and it uh it works so that's in the
function repository as well
you can see it here uh but
that's in my mind doesn't doesn't
qualify for a full-fledged cafes
because there's got to be some some web
stuff so
i'm not a css person but luckily i know
someone who is and i got him to spend
four minutes making this and
what i have here is cloud deploy of
delayed
so that delayed means that every time
you visit
the cloud object in a browser it's going
to re-run the code within it
and then what we have here is it get
runs random english iq
and then make sure that it works and if
it works
then it exports it within this
uh that html blob with the css in it
uh to to uh html so it looks good
um so i deploy this to cloud object
and now we get something that looks so
poetic
oh man bell birdie jiffy
drill untagged arrangement
cow heard morosely see it's just it just
tickles your soul that way um
all right so that is the the second
quick fun
hacky side project and now the
third one is one where
that i'm most proud of that i love the
most
and that's this baseball reference
player graph i'm a big baseball fan
hopefully there's there's some other
baseball fans
listening and if you are a baseball fan
you probably know about
baseballreference.com so
baseballreference.com
is a statistical wonderland this
website that's basically just an
interface to a database has been around
for an amazingly long time
something like 20 years since you know
since
all of the internet kind of looked like
this um
and you know it has importantly for us
for each year
2020 los angeles angels it has
statistics pages that include rosters
and it also has some other pages that
are important to us
so i have all the code that's running
here is
in my github i'll say again here you can
see this is
a hundred lines of code again a bunch of
white space
um so it's not not a whole lot going on
here most of it is basically this
import of a web page as an xml object
some sort of
pattern matching in cases to find
some content in that web page and then
grab those associations or create
associations from that content
uh so that that's mostly what's going on
here so the first thing i did was i took
this page which just
lists all the current teams in major
league baseball
uh this i think is a
plug in the 12.2 version i'm using um
but you can see it didn't seem to cause
any problems um
so here we have the teams along so team
names
and relative urls on baseball reference
then we can take one of those teams
and i have this function team years
so this says the boston red sox every
year they've been around
they've been around for a long time
since 1901 the
founding of the american league uh so
you can see they have 120 years
of teams so that means each one of those
past was one of those pages with the
roster and the statistics that we looked
at
a couple minutes ago then what i have
is this guy team year player graph
so that does is it takes uh the list of
teams and years they've existed
so basically if i had done this team
year this team years over all the teams
it would create the thing that's big and
ugly inside this iconized blob
so it takes that that set of teams and
years
and then you can give it a start year in
an end year and i'll run this last time
it took about
20 seconds um so while we're running
that
i'll tell you what it's doing it's
making a graph where
each vertex is a player uh
that was in major league baseball at the
time there we go 15 seconds it's getting
faster
let's plot it that takes a few seconds
too and each edge
represents a teammate relationship
between two players so if two players
played on the same team in the same year
uh they have an edge between them
now i know what you're thinking you're
saying bob
what if two players were traded for each
other
that means they played on the same teams
in the same years but they were not
actually teammates
and you know what you're right it's not
perfect
this is a quick fun hacky side project
all right so we have our graph and uh
so now that we have this computational
form for this data we can do all sorts
of cool stuff
so i can grab two vertices and
right now they're represented with
baseball references uh
you know id system but for any two
players i can find a path between them
on this graph and this
team your players graph in addition to
making the graph also edit annotations
so i can get their real names and i can
see that jesse jefferson played with
rick burlson who played with jim dwyer
who played with dallas williams so
now we have this cool computational
thing that you can play with
on your desktop computer and we're done
just kidding cloud deployment
uh so we can take this graph and export
it as
mx to a cloud object that yeah i did
that earlier it only takes a few seconds
and then what i can do is i can create
another cloud deploy of delay
again this means every time you visit it
it's going to run again
and it's calling this random story
function
on the graph so this import imports the
thing that we just exported
the graph and then it calls random story
and then it exports it as a cloud cdf
um so so when we visit this we get
this this random story steve crawford
played on the 1981
boston red sox with carney lansford
played on the 1980 los angeles landing
churches
with ed halicki who played on the 1980
san francisco giants
with alan ripley and if we refresh it
we get another story uh okay
so that's that's fun but that's just
1980 and 1981.
what about the rest of them well luckily
i've done the work for you
the scraping took a couple hours and
the result is this one
so now we've got er earlier ling and
jack delorio
and you can see maybe some names that
you recognize
let's get another one oh this is perfect
notice who's in the middle here
minnie minoso harold baines
remember those names uh so that's
connecting a player from 1951
with 2016. we'll go again see if we can
get somebody from
way back 1906 but he was only going to
1935.
anyway so this if
for me is solid minutes of
of fun um and if you're a baseball fan
i wouldn't be surprised if it's solid
minutes of fun for you
since we have this computational graph
of this fun new data i
figured i'd point out a few other things
there are
17 669 vertices representing players
just over 2 million edges representing
teammates
the graph diameter is nine so that means
any two players
are connected to each other by at most
seven
other players and i've pointed out mini
minister before
minnie minoso is the cave kevin bacon
paul erdos
of major league baseball this is an
important finding
uh there are he's minnie minoso is one
of 1388 players that are connected to
all players in five degrees or less
the top 20 players by between centrality
are these folks so this is why i have
minnie minnow so it's a great story
so indulge me for a minute minnie minoso
was
one of the first cubans in major league
baseball after
after jackie robinson broke the color
barrier uh when the first dark-skinned
cubans there was
all sorts of weird racism before that um
but he played a long career and then
after he had retired from playing he was
a coach with the white sox
and they had a player shortage i don't
remember the reason injuries
or labor dispute or something but they
needed a they needed a player
and they said minnie you want to play
and he played he played a
handful of games in his mid-50s and one
of the young players on that team was
harold banes
so between these guys uh you can connect
all the way from like 1950 to like
2003 or something so these guys are like
this great link
the other players on here also had long
careers some of them like julia franco
and nolan ryan played on a bunch of
teams
i also i've done further research that i
think is very important
there are many people with bacon minoso
numbers um
there's uh you know jackie robinson
played jackie robinson in the jackie
robinson story so he's in a movie
uh yeah whenever they make a baseball
movie they cast
some real players as extras to make it
look real
but as far as i've known with my
extensive 20 minutes of research
i don't think there's anyone with a
minosel air dust number
no major league baseball players have
have published in an academic journal
i could be wrong about that there's a
lot of retired baseball players that
become md's
but i haven't found any publications
from them another takeaway old-timey
baseball names are great
that might be my next cafes all right so
that was
the the last uh
one that i really wanted to point out uh
one thing worth mentioning as a
one side project it started on a while
ago when when
kovid was really first taking off in the
states at least
was a visualization tool for like a
metro area
because i saw a lot of stuff at the
state level and a lot of stuff
at the country level and even stuff at
the county level
but i live in st louis which is
on the border of two states and i cared
much more about what was happening
right on the other side of the border
than what was happening all the way on
the other side of the state
so i wanted to create like a metro area
one so that was a
hacky side project that i made but then
i kept working on it
and it eventually grew up into a
full-fledged packet with a whole bunch
of code in it so
even though it starts off as something
that's
you know as a lark uh these these hacky
things can become real so yeah
since since then every few days i've
been updating this metro area dashboard
for st
louis um so and and the code's
pretty generalized so you can put in put
in any any location you can
uh you know for for champagne we can get
the near seven counties
and there we go um
you can see what what counties are
peaking when
and sort of in this thick black line is
the the total
uh but yeah so these these tacky side
projects can grow up i don't want to
actually get into this project
um so yeah that is that is
the the talk um oh actually
there's the last second edition not in
the notebook unpathable
uh this morning new a new cafes
just for you guys let's see
giphy importer all right all right so i
will i will
check out the uh the pathable
chat and see what questions we have
all right all right
all right so i've got i've got more
comments than questions
kyle likes my wolfram shrine yeah that
was that was uh
oh yeah oh yeah and i forgot one thing i
pulled out of it pulled off of that
bookshelf
hey tony the rooster did you like my
baseball reference player graph
okay um you had to be seeing the video
not the screen share for that
all right and and so no question so i'll
just
summarize that uh you know when you have
encounter things in life and they seem
like they might
have some computational interesting
aspect to them
pursue it because you might get
something fun
you might uh get something useful
none of that was really useful but it
was fun uh the code thing's useful
and um
and yeah and if it turns out to be a
bust in the wolfram language
you're only gonna you're only gonna
waste a half hour so
all right um kyle's asking me if i'm
doing the the um the competition the
live coding thing yes
yes i think i will um there will be
there will be kids at home then so we'll
see
if they allow it but that's the plan
i am complicationally fun and so can you
signing off